we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p now this
voicemail going to play for you I
actually have received a lot of emails
about this this is the only voicemail
I've received about this but I have
received a lot of emails about the
locations from which some of our recent
guests have been appearing on the David
Pakman show take a listen to this hello
David I was just calling to say that
lately I've seen a few videos where
people are in their bedrooms you can see
their dresser you can see part of their
bed whatever it kinda I kind of really
don't like it I feel like I'm in the
same room with their dirty laundry and
it's just so not classy a piece of
plywood a curtain anything but your
bedroom where your dirty laundry is to
me that the screams unprofessional
anyways that's all I just shout out to
all the bedroom youtubers please stop it
thank you yeah so I when I first heard
this voicemail
I thought that they were talking about
some of our guests when I when we
connect they're in their bedroom and
it's sort of like listen if that's where
they're set up for the interview we're
gonna do it and I get a lot of emails
particularly from our viewers in Europe
who say you know David I don't know if
it's different in the United States but
in Europe the bedroom is considered sort
of a private place where you wouldn't do
like a national interview for radio and
television and online media from your
bedroom where you see your bed and it's
sort of surprising is this common for
Americans
this particular caller seems to be
referring more to youtubers who do
content from their bedrooms now I can't
think of any that do that I don't really
watch anything as I've said before but I
don't know of anybody I mean I've seen I
know Sam cedar has a set because I
obviously stole his intellectual
property to make my set so I know he's
got a set I don't know who else is is
shooting in their bedroom or whatever
but is is this something people care
about I want to hear from you what about
the bedroom scenes that are appearing
increasing on the David Packard
for guests and on YouTube we have a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the passing of John Conyers
the longest-serving black congressman
who has passed away at age 90 we will
talk about lift offering free rides to
job interviews and we will talk about
Betsy DeVos being held in contempt of
court for enforcing loans on defrauded
college students all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show become a
member or a patron to get instant access